I'm saying that's what you're saying
without you realizing it. Now go to
Matthew 6. Let me show you what the true
Jesus said about God. Go to Matthew 6.
Read verse 6 all the way to 8. I don't I
don't believe in the authenticity of
Matthew. But your prophet did. Are you
saying you're better than Muhammad? If I
show you from your Quran that your
prophet said, "Believe the Bible that I
have." Are you going to him with me?
Because I'm going to show you that right
now in the Quran. No. Okay. May I
explain? Um, no. Don't I don't need your
explanation. You just became a Muslim 2
months. You're not qualified. Do you
want me to show you in your Quran where
your faith prophet said, "My Bible is
true and I'm to use it to judge him and
then you can on him with me." It does it
does say that you you have to judge by
the Torah and the gospel. But that was
at the time of the prophet and Okay.
What prophet? What what prophet? the the
prophet Muhammad. Okay, now now you see
now you're a liar or you're ignorant
because you have copies of the Torah
that were written before Jesus, after
Jesus, during the time you're prophet,
and it's the same we have today. So when
did it change?
Um I I believe it's changed after the
the prophet Muhammad. That's okay. Good.
Oh, good. Good. Oh, wait, wait, good.
Because now I'm going to give you an
English translation of the copy of the
Old Testament from copies of the Bible
that were in 200 years before Jesus. So,
good. Now, let me show you that. Now,
you're stuck. You said after, right?
Okay. Let me give you a translation from
before. Good. Good. Good. One sec. Here
it is. There you go. Okay. I want you to
see this right
here. The Dead Sea Scrolls Bible. The
oldest known Bible translated for the
first time into English. This is the
Torah from the most ancient copies of
the Old Testament written in Hebrew
found in 1947. written about 20 years
before Jesus translated in English and
it's identical to what I read in my
Bible today and this is before Muhammad.
So you said after Muhammad now I got
copies before Muhammad. You're stuck.
Okay. So um with the whole um Bibles uh
from the time of Jesus or before him uh
peace be upon him. Um we're not sure. I
mean I I'm not sure. I don't know. Like
go to chapter 3 50. You better be sure.
Go to chapter 350 cuz your Quran says
Jesus confirmed what I'm holding right
now. Go to chapter 3 verse 50 of the
Quran. Yeah, I know. I know what you're
saying. Okay, read it. If you don't
know, don't read it. Chapter 3:50.
Okay. So, this is uh uh 350. And I will
confirm the Torah revealed before me and
legalize some of what had been forbidden
to you. I have come to you with a sign
from your Lord. So, be mindful of God
and obey me. Okay. He's going to do
what? What did your Quran say Jesus
supposedly did? Jesus confirms the Torah
given to Moses. Okay. Now, I'll give you
$10 million. Show me where it says the
Torah is given to Moses in your Quran.
The um Allah says that a book was given
to Moses and we know the book gives No,
no, you're not listening. No, no, no.
You don't know. You don't know what the
book is because the Quran doesn't tell
you. Don't play that game with me. Don't
steal from my Bible to defend your
position because you just rejected my
Bible. Show me in your Quran where it
says the Torah was given to Moses. Don't
play that game with me, son.
Um, I I can't think of I can't think of
a verse on top of my head because there
isn't. So, what I'm not going to let you
do is steal from my Bible, which tells
you the Torah is given to Moses because
you just said you don't believe it
because that means you're a hypocrite
like your prophet to go to my Bible to
tell me that the Torah is given to
Moses, but then when I use my Bible, I
don't believe it. You don't play that
game. Either you accept it or you reject
it. So I want you to show me in your
Quran where it says the Torah was given
to Moses right now. Show it to me. You
don't need to waste your time. It's not
there. But what I want you to look at is
what did Jesus do?
Jesus confirmed the Torah. Okay. Did it
say that he exposed corruption to the
Torah or he confirmed it?
No, he confirmed the Torah. Okay. Now go
to chapter 5:46.
Okay. So this is uh 546. Um that then in
the footsteps of the prophets, we sent
Jesus, son of Mary, confirming the Torah
revealed before him. And we gave him the
gospel containing guidance and light and
confirming what was revealed in the
Torah, a guide and a lesson to the
God-fearing. So let the people of the
gospel judge by what God has. Now you
went to 47. Well, read 47. Go ahead,
read it. It's okay. I wanted you to do
just 46, but read 47 since you're ready.
Sure. So, let the people of the gospel
judge by what God has revealed in it.
And those who do not judge by what God
has revealed are truly the rebellious.
Okay. Now, go to 61:6 of your Quran. And
I'm not even going to quote Ibn Kir. We
don't need Ibn Kafir to confirm what I'm
saying. Just you're reading in front of
your eyes with this Katib guy. Read
61:6.
[Music]
Sure. And remember when Jesus son of
Mary said, "Oh children of Israel, I am
truly God's messenger to you,"
confirming the Torah which came before
me. And giving good news of a messenger
after me whose name will be Ahmed. Yet
when the prophet came to them with clear
proofs, they said, "This is pure magic."
Okay. Now, I just gave you three verses
which you read. Jesus confirmed the
Torah that was there in his possession.
Not a single word about Jesus saying
it's corrupted. Now, I just showed you,
look at the title
again. The Dead Sea Scrolls Bible, the
oldest known Bible, translated for the
first time into English. Arch
archaeological proof tells us what the
Torah was because we found manuscripts
in Hebrew of the Torah, the Old
Testament, written before Jesus. That
means if you believe in your Quran, the
only Torah Jesus had historically, this
is a fact, is what I have today, and
it's right here.
So if you believe in your Quran, you
better stop telling me I reject your
Bible because that means you don't
believe in your
Quran. So coming back to the issue
whether you believe the Bible or not,
forget that you believe Bible. Let's say
you don't believe the Bible. It's
corrupted. Fine. But you're not
addressing the fact that I as a
Christian when I read the Bible, I see
that the God of the Bible wants
Christians to adopt children because
he's a God who loves to adopt people
into his family. Your God Allah not only
abolishes adoption. You can't adopt. He
doesn't adopt anyone. How can they be
the same God?
Convince me. I want to be Muslim.
Convince me someone who's been raised on
the Bible that Muhammad it believes in
the same God that Jesus believed in. And
when you tell me the Bible's corrupt, by
the way, when you tell me Bible's
corrupt, you're proving to me Muhammad
is a Do you know why? Because you
wouldn't tell me the Bible's corrupt if
Muhammad agreed with the Bible. But you
see, he doesn't agree with the Bible. So
you have to attack the Bible to deceive
me into following him.
Okay. But um there are things in the in
the Old Testament that um that that you
and the New Testament authors um like
interpret things like like from a
christoologgical point of view. So uh
why not use the Quran as the criteria?
Because Allah says in the why would I
use the Quran as a criteria when your
Quran in chapter 5 just said listen did
you read it? You didn't read it. It said
we Christians are to judge by the gospel
not the Quran. Did you read 547? You
just refuted yourself. Read it again.
Yeah, I did read it. Okay. So, as a
Christian who's not a Muslim, what am I
supposed to judge by according to your
Quran?
as according to the Quran. It's read it.
So let the people of the gospel judge by
what God has revealed in it. What's it
and those who do? It is the gospel.
Okay. So why did you just tell me use
the Quran as a criterion when your Quran
is telling me a Christian use my gospel
as a criterion?
Um now read 45. same chapter 45 to 40
I'm sorry 43 to 45 read chapter 5 verses
43 to 45
okay can I can I say something about um
this um it it did say that um you should
judge by by the gospel uh by what God
has revealed in the gospel but um Allah
also says that to not go extremes um in
in what you do I don't care what Allah
the Quran says because that's not the
gospel my gospel doesn't care what Allah
says but your Allah told you to tell me
to judge by my gospel. Is that what
Allah just told you to tell me?
Uh, yeah. It seems like So, don't tell
me, James, listen. Don't tell me what
your Allah says to you. I don't give a
damn. I'm telling you that you're
supposed to tell me cuz Allah told you
to tell me. You Christian, judge by your
gospel. So, I'm judging you by my
gospel.
Now read 40 43 to 40 45 to see that then
your Allah tells the Jews don't go to
Muhammad go to your Torah and judge by
it. Read 43 to 45. Same chapter. Okay.
Sure. Uh but why do they come to you for
judgment when they already have the
Torah containing God's judgment? Then
they turn away after all. They are not
true believers. Indeed, we revealed the
Torah containing guidance and light by
which the prophets who submitted
themselves to God made judgment for
Jews. So too did the rabbis and scholars
judge according to God's book with which
they were entrusted and of which they
were made keepers. So do not fear the
people fear me, nor trade my revelations
for a fleeting gain. And those who do
not judge by what God has revealed are
truly the disbelievers. We ordained for
them in the Torah a life for a life, an
eye for an eye, a nose for a nose, an
ear for an ear, a tooth for a tooth, and
for for wounds equal retaliation. But
whoever wasted charitably, it will be
atonement for them. And those who do not
judge by what God has revealed are truly
the wrongdoers. Okay. Can I ask you a
question? You read 43 to 45. It even
says to the Jews, why are the Jews
coming to you, Muhammad? Let them stick
with the Torah. So why are you now
telling me and the Jews to judge by your
Quran when your Quran tells you to tell
me Christian you judge by your gospel?
Jew don't come to Muhammad judge by your
Torah. So why are you contradicting your
Quran?
Um when when I read these verses I
understood it as like the Torah and the
gospel as being not corrupted yet at the
time of the prophet. Oh. So now when I
gave you copies of the Torah that were
discovered in 1947 that were written
before Jesus showing you that the only
Torah that Jesus would have confirmed is
what I have today and even proves it to
you because in 45 it says in the Torah
there's life for life, tooth for a
tooth. That verse is still in my Torah.
It's in
Exodus
21:22-2. So the very verse in 5:45
quoted it's there in what I read
today. Game over friend. That means your
attack on the Bible means you're
dishonest or ignorant. One of the two.
I'm going to be generous and say you're
ignorant because you didn't know much
about Islam, let alone about the Bible.
You know nothing about the Bible and
know very little about Islam. It is just
being honest. So now if I judge
according to the gospel, I'm going to do
what your Quran says. You Christian
Nasara judge by your gospel. Okay,
James. My gospel says God is the father
of believers spiritually. We are his
children through faith in Jesus. Jesus
said God is the father. I relate your
Quran. Allah is a father to no one.
Muhammad is in his is in his son and
you're not his son. Then how can the God
that Jesus preached about in my gospel
be your God?
I I'm not sure. Say it again.
I'm not sure. Okay, good. Hopefully God
will wake you up from your deception.